et je vous propose de répondre à une
autre question qui posait sur twitter
également ses six blanche neige est la
dernière victime de la fin de celle
culture alors vous pose la question
après cette nouvelle polémique autour de
l'héroïne de walt disney en cause
et bien vous allez le voir c'est une
scène que si vous avez vu où elle disney
si vous avez eu blanche nage si vous
avez lu vous la connaissez vous l'avez
forcément revues c'est cette scène quand
le prince va poser un baiser sur le
front de blanche neige pour la délivrer
du sommeil de la mort sommet de la mort
qui a été provoquée par la pomme croquée
et la pomme qui avait été donnée par une
sorcière qu'apporte un baiser qu'il lui
donne sans son consentement alors
qu'elle est endormi ne peut pas être du
véritable amour si une seule personne
c'est ce qu'il se passe c'est en tout
cas ce que dénonce le très sérieux sans
fin de cisco chronicle qui était un des
grands quotidiens en californie et les
deux journalistes ils sont spécialistes
question de cinéma à l'intérieur julie
tremaine et katie dowd et qui enchaîne
ne sommes nous pas d'accord pour dire
que le consentement dans les premiers
films de disney est un problème majeur
et qu'il faut apprendre aux enfants
qu'embrasser quand il n'a pas été établi
que les deux parties ont la volonté de
s'engager ne se fait pas interroge
ensuite les deux critiques
il est difficile de comprendre pourquoi
disneyland en 2021 fait le choix
d'ajouter une scène aux idées si
rétrograde sur ce qu'un homme est
autorisé à faire à une femme par disney
est invité à imaginer une autre fin ça
soulève une levée de boucliers chez les
partisans de plus en plus nombreuse
états unis de liberté d'expression
sophie faut-il faire comme disney une
mention en forme d'excusé pour l'instant
avec un pardon explications contextuel
faut-il imaginer une autre forme alors
quand on connait bien blanche neige que
moi qui ai beaucoup aimé blanche neige
on sait qu'il y avait ll a été
empoisonnée et elle a avalé un morceau
de pomme qui allait pas bien du tout
donc sin la paix par brassées est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas à temps c'est
important non assistance à personne en
danger
ensuite de sa la première version de
walt disney était que
il avait avalé un goût de pomme
empoisonnée et qui avait 1 1 qui avait
malencontreusement trébuché et que ça
lui a fait cracher celle-là réveiller et
cela fait cracher le bout de pommes donc
la première version n'était pas un
baiser
moi je préfère l'histoire du baiser en
plus franchement le baiser la version du
nain oui enfin non je préfère la version
du baiser qui sauvent salvateur c'est
très beau un baiser qui sauvent en plus
et j'ai regardé le baiser quand même bon
alors on regarde oui on a regardé le
baiser à nouveau va le ridicule
n'échappera à personne
le ridicule n'échappera à personne et il
faut pas oublier que dans certains états
aux états unis pour certaines pratiques
sexuelles
il fallait que l'homme demandent
l'autorisation à la femme par écrit
alors je vous laisse rêver donc il ya un
moment où il faut arrêter ces règles
n'étaient pas signés bris tous les excès
l'ordonné moment et pardonnez moi c'est
pour ça qu'on a montré qu'on pourra
montrer aux enfants non n'est pas dans
l'ordre de la pratique sexuelle du tout
bon et en plus c'est abusé sur le franc
ce qui m'a toujours semblé c'est qu'on a
bien vérifié je demandais à albane si on
peut remettre la scène est effectivement
donc l'offre voilà ça c'est là la
dernière scène mais effectivement de
enfin tous les cas ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
vu vous galvanise notre confiance que
j'ai une oreillette
c'était sur le front bon donc en tout
cas c'était paoli oui mais c'est pas
innocent on éclate de rire tout je
suppose qu'il ya 100% quand même je
pense enfin j'espère des gens qui
veulent pas changer blanche nuage
peut-être ma tombe en tout cas on pose
nous la question qu'on pose c'est si
blanche neige est la nouvelle victime
d'un camp de salle culturelle a alors
avant que vous me disiez que c'est pas
innocent
je vous propose en tout cas d'écouté
l'analyse de listeria keqin bossuet sur
sur ses news et on y revient justement
non moi je pense qu'il ya un véritable
engagement politique derrière tout cela
on veut tous dénaturer on veut tout
détruire tout ce qui constitue et
constitue le socle de notre identité est
le socle de notre civilisation donc on
s'en prend à nos grands personnages
historiques on s'en prend à nos
classiques en termes de romans s'en
prend également aux contes pour enfants
on pointe l'oeuvre du patriarcat partout
sans remettre l'oeuvre dans son contexte
et évidemment profondément ridicule et
c'est profondément dangereux alors c'est
profondément ridicule mais l'historien
la plus loin à l'iss est profondément
dangereux qui a mis une logique à
l'oeuvre derrière qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous adrien alors je suis partagé
mais peut-être pas sur le théme acronis
c'est une seule côté macro nice bon
alors évidemment ceci est grotesque dans
ce cas là on peut aussi annuler la belle
au bois dormant pas ce que c'est il me
semble que c'est la même chose
oui et ça va permis d'ailleurs de
pouvoir me mettre au clair au niveau de
mai wall dis pas ce que je pensais que
c'était plutôt la fin de la belle au
bois y effectuer mais effectivement la
précision par sophie oui alors c'est
ridicule effectivement c'est un petit
peu dangereux parce que ça participe
d'un mouvement idéologique qu'on appelle
le courant rock qui est surtout aux
états unis mais qui peut-être arrivé un
petit peu en france a comme moi qui ai
un petit peu au croisement du
puritanisme protestants américains et
d'une espèce de volonté de tout
déconstruire et de tout remettre en
question voilà pour les 10 et une
nouvelle religion qui remporte qui et
les réflexes sont religieux de ce n'est
pas pas excéder de puritanisme américain
qui rencontre le beau gosse il
exactement
voilà alors ça bah je suis 100% d'accord
en alu très intelligemment que ce
n'était pas de la déconstruction car
c'était de la destruction
oui alors ce qu'il ce qui est un petit
peu pas dans leur esprit alors moi je ne
sais pas ce que veut dire le mot des
constructions la destruction mais
bon je partage ce constat et qu'elles
sont à marianne on est quand même assez
engagé sur ce sujet là se grandirait
votre nuque dernier numéro où vous vous
recensez toutes les trahisons de la
gauche et celle aussi de la droite
oui
et c'est très intéressant très
instructif et pour ce qui est de la
droite c'est effectivement y'a rien à
jouer alors mais alors je quand même je
vais apporter une nuance sur ce sujet là
c'est que je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
ressentir un certain malaise face à ce
que j'estime être de
l'instrumentalisation de ces questions
là c'est à dire que j'ai bien regardé il
ya deux journalistes du san francisco
chronicle qui ont écrit un article sur
blanche neige
voilà c'est tout et alors on en parle au
figaro on en parle sur ses news
on en parle un peu partout des méchants
d'un parti dont fox news
mais en réalité ça va vous paraître
complètement démagogique ce que je vais
vous dire mais il ya quand même en
france 5 million trois cent mille
personnes qui souffrent de pauvreté
il ya une pandémie il ya la question
écologique il ya les inégalités et j'ai
l'impression que ya un certain courant
de pensée conservateur que je respecte
par ailleurs qui parle beaucoup de ça
qui dès qu'il ya un exemple trois
militants isolés qu'ils vont faire une
crise ridicule sur un sujet vous ont
passé des heures sur ce à jour etc ça
nous évite un peu de parler des vallées
des vrais sujets alors qu'ils voulaient
assujettir les médias font ce qu'ils
veulent et que une fois là bas
alors oui les bonnes questions
si je peux leur reprocher quand il
possible et pas empêché pour l'apéro
chez moi je fais le reproche mais donc
c'est effectivement grave parce que
monter en épingle certains faits peut
provoquer des réactions graves et et on
peut se poser la question
alors non mais la question qui est posée
par la question qui est posée par adrien
et
et la suivante est intéressante vous me
dîtes si je me trompe c'est que
finalement à dénoncer ce genre de ce
genre de choses l'encouragent
soit on encourage ou en tous les cas on
en fait trop on en fait des tonnes et on
donne trop d'importance
est ce que vous pensez et ça c'est une
vraie question c'est une vraie
différence
je vous dirai peut-être ce que j'en
pense sur la question mais est-ce que
vous prouver qu on donne trop
d'importance à ce genre de polémiques là
ou bien est ce que vous pensez comme
d'autres que parfois cette polémique la
passe ces choses-là passé inaperçu et
finalement c'est la meilleure façon
qu'elles qu'elles arrivent de façon
subreptice dans la société dans les
idées dans les moeurs votre question est
difficile parce que d'abord c'est
évidemment leur jeune âge c'est ridicule
bon ça détend marqué à la limite mais il
ya ce qu'on appelle le soft power et moi
je trouve que c'est très inquiétant soit
je vous poserai que je suis désolé mais
l'autre jour on parlait des matchs de
foot etc
moi je suis très scandalisé que les
mêmes qui financent des mosquées
islamistes en lisant sens parce qu'ils
financent des clubs de foot c'est aussi
un soft power que de financer des clubs
de foot et là on les idolâtres il ya eu
également l'histoire de du fameux
bouquet de jeff koons qu'on voulait
placer à un endroit très stratégique
culturellement qui dans le monde entier
quand on voyait paris on aurait vu le
bouquet de jeff koons qui a été relayée
heureusement dans les jardins derrière
les champs-elysées donc c'est compliqué
parce que ce qui paraît innocent ne
l'est pas aujourd'hui
donc est-ce que
on met sa troupe en exergue
je ne sais pas alors je vais vous faire
quand même je voudrais répondre à adrien
sur une chose parce qu'il a dit que
c'était une polémique qui ne concernait
que je cite le figaro faut 4 news et ses
news
bon c'est donc je fais blanche-neige 1
sur google
donc je le monte s'est vu qu'il y avait
le vent mais voilà et donc voilà vous
avez donc effectivement y avait à
l'heure actuelle ça ça vient de se
mettre tout de suite et vous avez donc
je fais juste google news donc j'ai
blanche dans la dépêche
glc ige la rtbf j'ai effectivement le
point également
si je puis me permettre je pense que
c'est pas quelque chose qui est cantonné
à l'orge en tous les cas dans l'écho qui
est donnée à une pour reprendre votre
votre votre expression un courant de
pensée simplement conservateur je pense
quand même que c'est l'apanage de plus
tôt de la droite de mettre en avant ces
sujets là une certaine droite d'être
contrôlé alors un peu contre l'euro que
non parce que pour le coup on est
nombreux à gauche à s'opposer à ce cours
a annoncé la même si on est moins
nombreux qu'à droite et moins nombreuses
alors encore une fois je suis partagé je
trouve ce courant inquiétant je trouve
qu'il a surtout de l' influence aux
états unis mais qu'il peut en avoir en
france dans certaines
dans certaines sphères comme
l'université par exemple ceci dit je
trouve qu'on en parle trop je trouve que
c'est pas un sujet majeur en tout cas en
france il avec des sujets plus intérêts
plus intéressant plus important et je
vais faire mon gros fail au je vais
citer mon ma directrice de la rédaction
natacha polony qui dans son édito de
marianne qui sort demain dit les débats
de prêtres télévisés qui ont besoin de
caricaturer d'opposition frontale mais
trouve plus facilement sur le sujet
identitaire que dans l'aridité des
questions économiques et je trouve que
l'on gagnerait quand même alors je
dansais sur le jeu se pose là je pose la
question est ce que justement c'est pas
une chimère et que justement parfois on
a oublié et que certaines questions
fondamentales c'est notamment ce qu'a
montré laurent bouvet et qu'ils étaient
des questions culturelles plutôt de
l'ordre culturel donc notamment quand
elle touche à l'identité sans être
identifiés sans je suis d'accord car
d'accord que c est plus important il ya
une forme de déni dans une certaine
gauche et dans une certaine droite
d'ailleurs
l économie qui ne peut pour l'économisme
ça a été la critique qui a été fait à
droite notamment quand de gaulle avait
dit me laissons le laissant à la gauche
à la culture à la gauche aly fera un
auchan un os à ronger et occupons nous
des questions importantes qui sont les
questions économiques et la question est
question politique et finalement c'est
la gauche qui a forgé les logiciels et
de l'autre côté
est-ce que effectivement il n'ya pas une
certaine gauche je reprends ce que vous
dites dans votre livre sur mélenchon qui
a refusé de voir certains nombre de
problèmes culturels en mettant la chose
que sur la question sociale s'est un peu
mélangé parce que effectivement il ya
une gauche qui est un petit peu dans
l'économie mais qui balaye d'un revers
de main les questions culturelles ceci
dit le principal reproche que j'ai à
faire à gauche c'est d'être empêtré dans
le sociétal et de défendre des positions
ou walk complètement hors sol qui à mon
avis parle pas du tout aux gens et de
pas se concentrer sur à mon avis ce qui
fait l'essentiel du coeur de ce que
c'est que la gauche c'est-à-dire
l'économique et le social vous oubliez
ça devrait la gauche a abandonné la
culture ce qui est navrant va pas
forcément pour la culture mais pour la
gauche et je trouve que c'est tout et
culturel on s'en sortira par la culture
l'absence d'une culture est un drame
bien sûr il faut dire que c'est pas
important la culture mais est ce que est
ce que la culture c'est se pencher sur
nos journalistes du san francisco
chronicle qui parle de blanche neige ça
c'est quand même dû parler du soft power
et c'est quand même une culture c'est
une culture de masse c'est qu'elle est
qu on leur donne assez de journalistes
qu'elle est qu'on met aux commandes je
vous recommande d'accord avec le constat
de beaux côtés de dérive de bock côté
oui mais ce qui est intéressant dans ce
que dit bon côté c'est que précisément
il dit par exemple sur la révolution
racialiste effectivement c'est très peu
à la marge aujourd'hui en france il dit
mais vous disiez la même chose du
politiquement correct au début des
années 90 ça vous paraît c'est dingue et
sahamies samedi 30 ans mais c'est arrivé
aujourd'hui
effectivement on est dans les questions
du politiquement correct être que là la
question c'est que en se saisissant du
moindre de la moindre anecdote pour un
petit peu hurler au loup on en voit une
forme de tribalisme vous aurez les gens
qui vont soutenir tous les trucs ou au
clic et que de ça donc on en parle comme
ça comme une famille bourgeoise on n'en
parle pas c'est pas la france hors de
question en effet on a fait en tout cas
merci beaucoup de ce débat tribution il
ya eu plusieurs points de vue qui ont
été donnés je me permets
à ce propos puisque on est
justement sans tabou donc on en a vu des
gens qui sont embrassés sur la bouche
maintenant je vais aller encore plus
loin des choses que quand même
d'habitude je rentre pas dans les dîners
chez moi en tout cas mes enfants mais
c'est très intéressant le dernier numéro
de charlie hebdo hors série sur
justement tout ce qui est là qu en salle
culture le wok d un sens c'est terminé
les offensés par permanent et vous avez
notamment un quiz
etes-vous hockey et je vous avoue s'est
trouvé là ça va ça va ça va déplaire
mais c'est il faut quand même le
reconnaître mais je trouvais ça très
drôle moins vulgaire et plus sérieux
mais tout aussi passionnant le nouveau
numéro de lentilles éditorial qui est le
nouveau média web lancé par jean pierre
denis l'ancien patron de la vie et il
recense toutes les initiatives aux états
unis pour contrer justement la
diminution de la liberté d'expression
qui est voulu parler entraîné par l'e
book est réclamée par part par le haut
qu'ils nous en tout cas par la grande
salle culture et c'est très intéressant
et c'est vraiment un mouvement également
qui monte et on pourra avoir un autre
débat si justement tu sais pas mais pas
aussi lanceurs d'alertés non dans ce cas
là et puis l'enquète d'alexandre ii
vecchio ces personnes qui refusent
d'être racisées 1 c'est un autre domaine
mais qui est connexe
en tous les cas du point de vue d'un
certain nombre de ses militants qui sont
intersectionnelle et effectivement on
recommande encore une fois mathieu
bock-côté la révolution racialiste pour
une raison notamment parce que justement
il lui en tout cas veut lancer l' alerte
et ça mérite en tous les cas je pense à
ce niveau-là de d'études d'étudier et
tout cas les ressorts ce qui est moins
intéressant c'est bien sûr tout ce
qu'ils racontent de la révolution
racialiste mais tout ce que des
logiciels un peu totalisant outre
totaliser près totalitaire que ça que ça
suppose sûrs sur la liberté d'expression
et c'est pour ça que on s'est permis de
mettre ce sujet sur la table
effectivement il y en a d'autres et on
reviendra sans doute sur les autres
sujets dans les prochains heures tous
les cas elles le sont sur le site du
figaro est également sur figaro live si
vous n'êtes pas abonné sur la newsletter
c'est l'occasion d'ailleurs de le faire
et comme ça vous aurez toutes les vidéos
et toute l'actualité toutes les images
qui ne fallait pas manquer dont bien sûr
cet excellent débat convient d'avoir
dans point de vue merci beaucoup à très
vite sur figure life